nous sommes ici au niveau de l'autoroute
e40 qui relie g.thomas à kiev il s'agit
d'une des routes les plus dangereuses
d'ukraine c'est un accès principal ou ne
passe que quelques rares véhicules dans
la direction de kiev des véhicules armés
ainsi que quelques camions qui apportent
de l'aide humanitaire et dans la
direction opposée venant de kiev et des
villages autour des bus et des véhicules
qui transportent des civils qui fuient
la guerre beaucoup de militaires ici
ainsi que des civils qui ont voulu
apporter leur soutien à leurs armées et
à leur pays via s'inscrivent sur day a
pris 2,6 millions
c'est tout ça qui cherche toujours des
sourires brisk
newman a
aussi analysé
nass mlah
rona matches
amicaux des mois à venir on a de nouveau
joué ou pas tout le monde surtout
toulouse 2-0 curieusement boys in blue
storm le projet est une menace très bon
à prendre jacques moussavi occasions
ratées coup d'après
même si ces territoires sont toujours
tenues par la main et ukrainienne la
menace russe se fait de plus en plus
pressante à moins de 100 mètres de
l'autoroute e40 une nouvelle frappe
russe qui a encore fait beaucoup de
dégâts